[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have been uh
trying to decipher exactly who won who
lost what's in store for us with the nba
with james harden and that
trade when kyrie comes back whose team
is it
and we love to throw out these questions
who's going to take the last shot
whose team is this who's that i don't
know how about we get kyrie back and
start there
frank isola is uh covering the nba and
has been doing so for decades sirius xm
nba radio the starting lineup host
espn around the horn pardon the
interruption contributor and also works
pre and post with uh the nets and uh we
thought frank would be a great person to
have on frank how do you feel
about your nets after this deal
well it's certainly a blockbuster dan
and i think you know a couple of things
happened early on in the season spencer
didn't what he went down
and then the situation with kyrie irving
so i think for the brooklyn nets when
you got a guy like kevin durant
you know your window is now it's not
about the past it's not about the future
and
obviously they gave up a lot of their
future with those draft picks i think
you owe it to yourself and to kevin
durant to go for it
so if dinwiddie didn't get hurt and
kyrie irving was playing and playing
well and the nets were playing well
i don't know if they do this you know
there's a little desperation there but i
also think
you know the one thing about james
harden he shows up out of shape
but the guy will play he could still
score points and you just mentioned
about kyrie whose team is well he's not
here
so i can't rely on him i know that i
could count on
kevin durant i know that i can count on
james harden and it's a superstar driven
league and i think that's why they made
this move
but we're very casual about the kyrie
irving situation
it's and i don't understand it we don't
know anything
he's shown up on zoom he's shown up at a
birthday party without a mask on
and then we almost i don't know it just
goes along with kyrie like yeah
well we don't know when kyrie's coming
back
what is going on with kyrie irving frank
you know it's
i thought the same thing so for the past
week or so ever since you know he
last time he played against utah he had
18 points in the first quarter he hasn't
played a lot of games with the nets
that was the best game he'd ever played
and we haven't seen him since then but
i'm laughing because
he hasn't been around for a week the
nets make this trade and everyone's
saying well the nets have a big three
they have a big three
well who are the three i know if two of
them i know kevin durant and james
harden
i don't know about kyrie irving and if
and when he does return
how do we know that he's all in how do
we know that a couple of months from now
there's going to be something
going on in his life or around the world
that could upset him and he has to take
some time off
so i don't know the reason why it's not
there and that's i guess that's
obviously his business but from a net
standpoint if i'm them i'm thinking
i just can't count on him he's not
reliable at this point
he just isn't he's missed a lot of time
over the years with injury now you have
this situation so i don't know exactly
where it stands and i think that also
factored into it look at the games
played for james hard
the guy plays basketball i don't like
the way he handled
his departure from houston he's not
going to win the nobel prize for the way
he handled himself
in the past month but the dude plays
when he's he's 15 pounds overweight
and he'll still put up 35 points so i
know i can count on him unfortunately
the nets
as of this moment can't count on kyrie
irving
how does this all work
well the one thing you noticed from
watching kevin durant and remember he
had gone 560 days
between playing games and we all know
that he's a great player but when you
see him out there and i'm getting to
watch every minute that he plays now
the guy is so good and he makes the
right basketball plays he doesn't take
bad shots
he trusts his teammates he is the very
definition
of a superstar there are great players
in the nba and then you have those
top of the top and lebron is up there
and kevin durant is up there kawhi
leonard maybe a couple of other players
so i believe that he'll make it work and
i think hardin could fit in
the big question mark the wild card in
this whole thing will be kyrie irving
how will he feel
when the ball isn't in his hands so that
part of it is going to be a struggle
and remember this the nets have been a
very poor defensive team
and a poor rebounding team and jared
allen is a
i know he doesn't move the needle he's a
solid role player he had been their
second best player this year
cary silvert was the team's best player
last year the third best player this
year
those guys play hard they're unselfish
they do what's ever told to them they're
low maintenance so
you know not having those role players
on the team will make an impact but when
you get a chance to get a superstar
it's a move that you have to make even
though the nets gave up a lot of draft
picks
i mentioned this a couple times on the
show today and that is you have to have
guys who understand what their role is
you go back to chris bosh in miami
kevin love in cleveland even some of the
golden state warriors when kd got there
they
they understood their role and i think
bosch was just as important as the other
two with the success of the miami heat
because
he didn't cause any problems he said
tell me what you want me to do
you want me to be a spot-up three-point
shooter kevin loved the same way
it's a delicate ego balance here with
three alphas there
in brooklyn on who knows what their role
is depending on
the time you know in the game here frank
or what's at stake
yeah and i i think it's true of
basically everything i mean look at you
guys you're the star of the show then
you have a guy that you know
checks the lottery tickets everybody
knows their role in the great
in the great documentary with the eagles
the late great glen frye he was pretty
interesting he says everybody wants to
play quarterback because it was one of
the band members that wanted to sing and
he said you know we have don henley
you're not singing and it it's just
interesting how
every situation has a dynamic like that
i would only say this about kevin durant
especially now he went to a great
situation
in golden state where you have selfless
players like steph curry clay thompson
draymond green but he was part of an
ensemble cast there
and they did win two nba finals they
would have won a third had he not gotten
hurt
and then you look at what he did in
oklahoma city now he was much younger
back then
but i i think when you recognize that
he's the best player and he's going to
make all the right plays just like what
lebron does
and that's why lebron in miami wade had
already won a title but he goes there
and look what he did for chris bosh's
career
look what he did for kyrie irving and
kevin love and look what he's doing
right now for anthony davis he changes
everything kevin durant has that same
ability to do it
i think james harden recognizes that you
would hope that kyrie irving would
recognize it too
because he did play with lebron james
now he wanted to get out of there
eventually
which to me is still a little confusing
so think about this dan kyrie irving
played with lebron
and eventually didn't want to be there
anymore now he's playing with kevin
durant
and he's not there you're you've had the
opportunity to play with the two best
players in the league and you're not all
the way in and i've said it
uh when lebron goes into the hall of
fame i'm pretty sure he's probably gonna
end up there one day
the top of his plaque it's not gonna say
all-time leading scorer five six seven
how many titles he wins it's gonna say
won a championship with kyrie irving as
his second best player right now
that's a pretty big accomplishment
what do you think lebron and the lakers
are feeling about this deal
i don't think they're worried at all i
think first of all let's give lebron a
lot of credit he's played in all 13
games
he's played back to back you know he's
36 years old more games more minutes
than anybody else he's played like i
think it's 270 playoff games
so that guy you could tell that he sees
the light at the end of the tunnel
meaning another championship
i don't think they're that worried about
the brooklyn nets he's probably a little
bit more worried
about the clippers just because paul
george to his credit who was awful in
the bubble
the last time we saw him he hit the side
of the backboard on a jump shot
he's actually played very well kawhi is
playing well but right now the western
conference doesn't look as tough as
everybody thought it did
but i'm sure lebron is looking at the
situation saying that's fine
but i'm pretty confident i could beat
them in the finals but kevin durant is
probably thinking you know what
i beat you twice in the finals i'd like
to get back there and challenge you one
more time
good to talk to you frank as always
thanks for joining us we appreciate your
time
yeah keep me involved in that uh when we
find out if we won the lottery if we
won the lottery he won the lottery frank
isola sirius xm nba radio the starting
lineup
and uh pre and post with the nets